It's hard to anticipate what might happen
on Game of Thrones, especially now that the
HBO show has bypassed its source material.
The eighth and final season of Thrones is
no exception to this rule of unpredictability,
but the most recent episode may have actually
spoiled the finale.
A melancholy song Lady Brienne's squire Podrick,
played by Daniel Portman, sings during "A
Knight of the Seven Kingdoms" seems to foreshadow
which person vying for the Iron Throne will
end up ruling.
Warning: Spoilers ahead.
The musical moment happens while Podrick,
Brienne, Jaime Lannister, Tormund Giantsbane,
Tyrion Lannister, and Ser Davos Seaworth are
gathered around a fire, awaiting the arrival
of the Night King and the Army of the Dead.
They drink and reminisce on past battles on
what could be the last night of their lives.
When the wine runs out, Tyrion requests someone
sing a song.
No one but Podrick pipes up, and he begins
singing a mournful tune:
"High in the halls of the kings who are gone
/ Jenny would dance with her ghosts"
He continues, with lyrics about how Jenny
couldn't remember the ghosts' names, but they
took away her sorrow and pain by spinning
her on an old stone.
The song then repeats that she "never wanted
to leave."
This scene did more than just tug on heartstrings
as it played over shots of our heroes in Winterfell
readying themselves for battle.
It evoked the mood Pippin created when he
sang "The Edge of Night" ahead of the Battle
of Osgiliath in The Lord of the Rings.
In the A Song of Ice and Fire books, this
tune is titled "Jenny's Song," and is directly
connected to the series' central characters
and their ancestors.
"Jenny's Song" appears in the novels as one
of the Ghost of High Heart's favorite songs,
which she refers to as "my Jenny's song."
Jenny is Jenny of Oldstones, a low-status
woman who married Prince Duncan Targaryen.
Their union, which Prince Duncan's father,
King Aegon V, disapproved of, spurred Prince
Duncan to renounce his claim to the Iron Throne
despite being the rightful heir.
In the same way Jaime Lannister shoved Bran
Stark out of a Winterfell tower to protect
his incestuous relationship with his sister
Cersei, Prince Duncan made the bold decision
to abdicate the throne to marry Jenny.
Not only does Jenny and Duncan's story mirror
that of Jaime and Cersei's, it it also parallels
two other Targaryens: Jon Snow, whose real
name is Aegon Targaryen, and Daenerys.
In episode 2, Jon reveals to his lady love
that he's actually her nephew, the son of
her brother Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark.
That makes him the rightful heir to the Iron
Throne, given he's a living male descendent
of Aerys "The Mad King" Targaryen.
Podrick singing "Jenny's Song" just before
that conversation happens might foreshadow
the events of the Game of Thrones finale:
Jon could relinquish his power to be with
Daenerys, just as Prince Duncan did.
It's doubtful that Podrick knew everything
about Jon's parentage and the story of Jenny
and Duncan when he decided to sing the sad
tune, but there's even more hidden meaning
in the song that supports the idea Jon may
give up the Iron Throne to be with Daenerys.
"You didn't tell me you were going to abandon
your crown."
"I never wanted a crown."
The Ghost of High Heart is thought to be the
first person who delivered the prophecy that
Aerys and Rhaella Targaryen, Dany's parents
and Jon's grandparents, would be the ancestors
of the "Prince That Was Promised."
Rhaegar, Dany's brother, grew obsessive over
the prophecy, believing he was the Prince
That Was Promised.
He thought that if he wasn't the Prince, one
of his children would be.
As Vanity Fair notes, Rhaegar may have actually
written "Jenny's Song."
In the books, during the Tourney of Harrenhal,
he plays a song for his love Lyanna Stark,
Jon Snow's mother.
It's not out of the realm of possibility that
the tune was the one Podrick sang.
Just after Podrick sings "Jenny's Song," Jon
and Daenerys stand in front of Lyanna Stark's
statue in the Winterfell crypts.
Daenerys says about Rhaegar:
"Everyone told me he was decent and kind.
He liked to sing."
There stands a chance that "Jenny's Song"
is more about the Prince that Was Promised
prophecy than Jenny herself.
It tells the story of the true-born heir to
the Iron Throne giving up everything for love.
Jon, Rhaegar's son, might be both the Prince
That Was Promised and someone who, like his
ancestor Duncan, surrenders his claim to kingship.
There really is no telling whether "Jenny's
Song" and its many meanings reflect how the
series will conclude, or whether Jon will
actually choose love over power, but there's
a chance that the tune hints at what will
happen.
If it winds up that "Jenny's Song" is nothing
more than a tune sung at an emotional time,
at least Daniel Portman got to prove he has
the voice of an angel.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.